my magenta my purse questions you got to
media that particular reference
countries in Asia I was yesterday why I
think so sweetheart but seriously that's
beautiful 11 factorization what said
Tony Curtis the Communist creation
social medias arraignment references
give the customers and give access and
launching new products in cement seven
swords and this needs to change I will
now consult visitors with me ever since
the windows to transition to the
coverage on him down we had to actually
learn about you actually we have to
actually go with them and implicitly to
them get help enable our perception give
you a lot of feedback have personally
deal with the problem a lot more
effectively and first we get way if not
just a second language foreign service
is the way to not just create opinions
but mentally or how products are
launched and production in people and so
so your customers in pune body company
social media is becoming a negative
message service direction
the other thing that was listed in fact
how he has affected generation younger
generations of engagement intimidated a
second largest Muslim world no.4 CRF
surprising and point that i was able to
raise was that who should media gave us
a message look another team and allowed
people to voice attention for its
support we're supposed man and when she
wouldn't without needing to be
identified and I salute so this
resultant commandment in Crete getting
onto his back negative had a great fall
winter and spring the Arab Spring
percent of the government will happen to
the fifth do not Japan for this new era
of social media which result in
communication across the mountains from
the kitchen server instantaneous and
that resulted in the factors they were
able to add them all into communication
no tax and I'm right rising in a sense
developed into a life cultural
difference crazy here you how to a
different service usually excuse Oh
Ganesha what in the West our social
interactions limited simply by the fact
that you're the best such an invention
itself outside the frame of reference on
yes by my citizens in a limited to the
number we invite so wedding on to a
party and sorting through Asia not much
same exercises wedding and I wonder
people is a small wedding is willing for
it not as collateral likewise so the
cultural gap it's not for this measure
the site's where we got such as the
photo sharing site
gloucester issues we when there's
expanded from the existing social norms
creating the fasted load and greater
promotion in a sense that is also part
impossible for existing social scenario
discussions all that all that social
media has come today is a new modality
nothing else what is it with that and
this come has stated it is time for a
change